[Music]  welcome back to the things disney fans  of all the disney villains maleficent is  one of the most  iconic those horns that flowing cape  but what if fairy godmother waved her  magic wand  and transformed maleficent into a disney  princess  just see how different maleficent looks  when she lets her hair down  or should we say horns and lets her  goodness shine through  it'll shine right to the top of her new  scepter which she'll use for nice spells  of course  she's going to need to kick her pet  raven diablo to the curb too  and get herself a new sidekick that's  much more befitting of a princess  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  broken glass  [Music]  broken hearts  all the hurt  all the scars  fading out  gone for good  you finally found yourself  you're finally understood  so you're getting up you wipe the dirt  and you shake the dust  get the best of us  [Music]  oh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you